The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, here we go.
All set, and two
topics for today--
one is to go back to
Professor Sra's lecture.
That was last Friday.
And he promised a
theorem and proof.
And this morning,
he sent it to me.
So it's proving the convergence
of stochastic gradient descent.
And really, what's
important, maybe,
and useful is not so much
the details of the proof,
which I'm just learning,
but the assumptions--
what's the logic
here, what do you
have to assume about
the gradient and about
the algorithm to get the answer?
But now I actually look back
at the video of his lecture.
And it was excellent.
And as I looked at it, there
were a couple of things
later in the lecture
that I thought
would make good projects.
So I don't know if
anybody is still
open to what to do on a project.
But here are my two ideas.
And if you've already
finished your project,
well, you get an A-plus by
considering one of these.
So you remember-- and
this will remind you
of the lecture, which
is a good thing.
So do you remember that
question 1 was whether,
in the stochastic part, after
you've sampled one or some mini
batch-- but let's just say
one of the lost functions,
coming from one sample--
you remember, the whole point
is that if we do all zillion
samples at every iteration,
we're really, really slow.
So the stochastic idea
is to randomly pick
one or a mini batch
of the samples
and just reduce their loss,
just deal with the loss--
say, the square loss.
Or later we'll see
cross-entropy loss.
But whatever the cost
is, just do a few or one.
And then the question was,
after you've done that one,
do you put it back
in the pot every time
you sample over the
whole collection?
But that's expensive.
Or do you just make a list of
random order of all the samples
and go through them?
Which is then without
replacement, which
is a sort of semi-illegal.
That is, the logic
in the randomization
asks you to replace every time.
But nobody does it.
It costs a lot--
probably not worth it.
So the project would be,
suppose you take 1,000--
or, say, just 100.
100 random numbers--
say you use MATLAB, just
the command "rand."
So you get numbers whose
average is a half from rand.
They're between 0 and 1.
OK.
So we know what the average is.
So let's compute it two ways.
One is by not replacing.
And that's the interesting one.
So take 100 samples.
Well, I guess we know
that, after we've
got through the full
100, we're going to get
exactly the right answer.
But anyway, my question would
be, how much difference do you
see in the eventual approach--
so the law of large numbers,
I guess, would tell
us we get a average
of a half for these numbers
with uniform distribution
between 0 and 1.
Should I be writing
anything here?
Maybe I should.
OK.
So this is project 1.
You pick numbers ak,
which is from rand--
so uniformly on 0,1.
And then my question is,
what about convergence
to the final--
the average is a half.
So this may be too
simple an example.
But could we see what
happens for the convergence
of the average as you either
do replacements or don't
do replacements?
And in fact, I would like
to see a figure that looks
like those in his lecture.
Do you remember?
He started it somewhere--
start-- and then
here's the finish.
But you remember, the
stochastic gradient descent
was kind of pretty
effective at the beginning.
Well, the beginning,
those might be 100
iterations each-- one epoch,
one run through the full number.
But then when it got
to here, got closer,
it started oscillating.
You remember, he identified
the region of confusion
around the thing.
Well, my suggestion
is just, I think
those videos should be
accessible to you on--
are they on Stellar?
Yeah.
So I'd love to see that
behavior and some good examples
of that behavior and
some pictures to you.
So that would be one
idea with and with--
oh, yeah, that's also idea 2.
Idea 2 is the good
start and then
the bad finish for a
stochastic gradient descent.
And of course,
even without this,
the magic words in computations
is "early stopping."
We don't over-fit.
So we wanted to
stop early, anyway.
And early stopping
just is a good idea
if that's what the
approach to the x
star that you're looking for.
This would be the
place where the--
that's x star where
grad f at x star is 0.
That's the minimum point.
That's ARG MIN-- exactly
what we're looking for.
And we don't find it very well.
But we get close to it fast.
OK.
Two ideas on projects--
so maybe I'll go to the
main topic of today--
the topic I promised--
the idea of back propagation.
This is all to compute grad f--
the gradient.
All the derivatives-- this
is the df dx1 to df dxm,
maybe, I'll say, where I have
m features for the sample.
OK.
So that's back propagation.
And that's the thing whose
discovery, or rediscovery,
put neural nets on the map.
That's the key calculation, of
course, to find the gradient.
In the steepest
descent algorithm,
every step needs a gradient.
And if you can't compute it
quickly, you're in bad shape.
But you can compute
it quickly by
this automatic differentiation
in reverse mode, which
is otherwise known--
I don't think the people--
maybe Hinton was the leader
in developing deep neural net--
deep learning.
So I give him big
credit for that--
that back propagation would
work and would give him
fast gradients.
But it actually had been studied
before under the name AD--
Automatic Differentiation.
So may I just tell
you that idea?
Some of you may know
it, may know about it,
may know more than I, and
might know a good website
to see this description.
There will be, of course,
a section of the notes,
you already have it.
This is section 7.2.
So this is the chapter
on deep learning.
And the first section was
about the structure of F of x.
And you remember the key
point about the structure
of F of x is that I start with
x and apply some function, F1
of x.
And to that, I apply
some function, F2 of x.
And to that, I
apply some function
of F3 of F2 of F1 of x.
And that's the thing
whose derivative I need.
So I'll just take
ordinary derivative--
well, partial
derivatives, really.
Yeah, I better say
partial derivatives.
So suppose x is a pair, xy.
Example-- so here, let
me show you my example.
So suppose F of x is--
let me take a simple example--
x cubed times x plus 2y.
OK.
So I want to think of that
function the way anybody would,
as the product of two functions.
So there is a product rule
to get into the derivative.
And then we need the
derivatives of each piece.
So there's a power rule and
a linear combination rule.
So it's got a few of
the rules that we use.
And the point is to think
about the computation
of F of x and the
computation of dF dx
and the computation of dF dy.
Those are the
derivatives that we need.
This is the function
we need and how
to do those
computations quickly.
OK.
And this is section 7.2, which
benefited a lot from a blog.
I'm not a blog reader
or a blog writer.
But somehow I found this blog.
It's Christopher
Olah, is his name.
And he really
writes clear things.
He works for one of
the big companies
and does the deeper research.
But he's also a
really good expositor.
And the website
that he now uses is
called Distill dot something.
But I think maybe this
blog was earlier than
before the start of Distill.
But it might be
loaded onto Distill.
Anyway, that's where I got
this simple description
of back propagation.
And let's just do
calculus, first of all.
If I just have a function
of maybe even one variable,
what's the derivative?
What is dF dx here,
just to remember
what calculation we have to do?
So dF dx, this is
with n equal one--
one variable.
So I use ordinary derivative
and not partial derivative.
But that's what
really has to be done.
But just, what's the
derivative of that--
of a chain of functions?
Well, of course, the chain rule.
So what does the chain rule say?
I differentiate dF.
I don't know.
What do I put that it's
differentiated with respect to?
dF3, dF2-- is that
what I should put?
OK.
And where do I evaluate
that derivative?
So yeah, I don't
evaluate it at x.
I'm differentiated to F2.
So do I evaluate it
at F2 of F1 of x?
This is where the chain rule
gets sort of a little chain-ey.
OK.
Then we know that dF2 dF1.
And again, that's now
evaluated at F1 of x.
And then the final factor
is dF1 dx evaluated at x.
That's somehow
what we have to do.
And that's just for an
ordinary one-variable function.
And I have here a
two-variable function.
And deep learning has a
million-variable function.
So I think we won't
go to a million.
But two, we could manage.
So let's compute the
function, first of all.
Compute F. So I'm
given x equals, say, 2,
and y equals, say, 3.
And I'm going to create
a computational graph.
So I'm actually going to
draw the computational graph
to compute for F. And then it'll
be a variation of that graph
to find the derivatives.
So let's just start with
the graph, first of all,
for the function, because
we're going to need that.
So again, it's x cubed plus--
so can I write that function
again? x cubed times x plus 2y.
So I think the first step will
be to find x plus x cubed--
that factor, which will be 8.
And we have to find the
other factor, x plus 2y.
So then that uses y and x.
So it's a directed
graph in going forward
with this computation.
So x plus 2y equals
whatever it is--
2 and 6-- oh, 8 again.
Not brilliant.
What shall I change here?
Make it 3y?
3y, just to get a
different number here.
So now x is 2.
y is 3.
I get 11.
That's a good number.
11.
OK.
So far, so good?
And now the next step
on this graph will be,
I have a product of those.
So that will go to the product.
F equals 8 times 11--
88.
OK.
So we've got the answer,
88, which, normally, I
wouldn't take that
much of a book
to compute F. I would have said,
2 cubed times 2 plus 3 times 3.
And I'd have simplified
that to 8 times 11.
And I would have got 88.
So if we were just writing
normally, that would do it.
But this is the picture of
the computational graph.
OK.
Good.
Now it's the derivatives--
two derivatives to
find-- dF dx and dF dy.
Suppose we go forward first.
My point is going to
be-- or the great point
is that backward is better.
Reverse mode is better.
But we don't know what that
means until we've gone forward.
So let me go forward.
So now I'm going to go forward.
Let's do dF dx.
Everybody is up for dF
dx-- the partial derivative
with respect to x?
So here we have x
equal 2 and y equal 3.
OK.
And then I take the
derivative of that step.
The first step was x 2x cubed.
So I need the derivative.
The whole point of AD is
that every computation
of a derivative breaks down like
this into very simple pieces.
And the derivatives
of those simple pieces
are also simple pieces.
So the whole point is
to replace appropriately
those intermediate
steps with derivatives,
so as to compute
the x derivative.
So I have to use the fact
that the derivative of x
cubed, with respect to x--
oh, I better do partial
derivative-- partial
derivatives of x cube, with
respect to x, is 3x squared.
I'll put maybe a formula
and then a number.
So that gives 3 times 4--
12.
And the derivative of x
cubed, with respect to y,
gives 0, clearly.
So that's 0.
So I'm doing the x derivative.
So the derivative of y,
with respect to x, is--
you get to tell me.
If I'm computing partial
derivatives, it is 0.
It is 0.
y and x are independent.
And this is the
reason, in my view,
that the forward
method is wasteful,
because I'm going to have to do
another whole graph for the y
derivative.
In other words, tracking
the x derivatives,
a whole lot of stuff
never got off the ground.
So we never should
have looked at it.
So anyway, I have
this x plus 3y, maybe.
I don't know whether
to erase that.
I think I will,
just because I don't
know what to do with it there.
Yeah.
So now let me take the
ones that I really need,
is the derivative, with respect
to x, of x plus 3y, which is 1.
And so that gives me the
answer 1 for any x actually.
OK.
And now what?
Oh, yeah, I don't need these.
This is a waste of time.
Isn't it?
Is it only x derivatives I want?
Anyway, let's just keep going.
You can see, this takes
a little organization.
And I'm not practiced with it.
So what am I going to do?
I'm looking for the
x derivative of--
I've got to use our
product rule now.
I found the x derivative
of that factor was 12.
The x derivative of
this factor is 1.
And now the x derivative
of the product--
so now I'm going to do,
somehow, a product rule--
the x derivative
of this product.
I should have given
these two terms a name.
Let me call that first term x
cubed, and the second term x
plus 3y--
call it s.
So I'll call the
two terms c and s.
So that's dc ds.
This is dc dx.
And this one is ds dx and dc dy.
Do I need to know that?
I'm sorry, this computational
graph has thrown me.
But now I want to
use the product rule.
And I'm taking x derivatives.
So I should have
computed c and s.
Yes, I see I need those
in the product rule.
So I should have computed c
as being 8 and s as being 5.
Is that right?
2 plus 3-- so 11.
Yeah, I needed the 8.
Oh, is that-- what's up?
I've just been
running along here
without getting myself
in the whole picture.
Yeah, 8 and 11 is right.
But now I'm looking
for the derivatives.
So I don't multiply those.
That's not the product rule.
So the product rule is what?
So this product rule, I have
to do this combination of--
this is now the product rule--
for the derivative of c times s.
So I want c ds dx plus s dc dx.
I think I'm on track now.
And now I want to
put it in numbers.
So c is 8.
ds dx-- have we computed ds dx?
Yes, ds dx is 1.
And now s itself
is computed as 11.
And dc dx, we computed as 12.
I don't dare look.
I don't think I'm going to get--
oh, no, I don't
know the answer yet.
Sorry, I'm not trying to get 88.
You guys are not helping.
[LAUGHS]
You see I'm in trouble.
But what I imagine here is,
that's 8 and that's 132.
So I'm getting 140.
Is there any
possibility that that's
the right answer for dF dx?
This is dF dx I computed.
By watching me struggle
here, you're seeing the idea.
Every step, I take the
derivative of each step.
So it was a power step, x cubed.
So I had a 3x squared.
And a sum step, so I had a 1.
Then the next step
was a multiplication.
So I needed the
product rule for that.
I have these separate numbers.
So I put them in.
And so it's the
computational graph finished.
We only needed two levels.
And we got 8 and 132--
140.
OK.
But we didn't get dF dy yet.
And for that, I'd need
to redo this again.
And I don't want to do that.
I would rather do the reverse
mode and do them both at once.
That's the point of
the reverse mode.
It's very efficient.
It's very efficient, actually.
Computing the
gradient after you've
done the work for the function,
computing first derivatives--
you could compute
n first derivatives
with about four or five
times the cost, not n times.
That's amazing to me.
That is amazing that I can
compute the gradient very
efficiently by the back prop.
So I have to show you
the backwards way.
Yeah.
I'm just going to follow all
the paths backwards so that I
get both dF dx and dF dy.
You see, the idea is to take
the derivative of each step--
each small step.
That's really what
we do in calculus.
If you think about the
start of a calculus course,
what derivatives do
we actually know?
Do we actually use F at
x plus delta x minus F?
What derivatives
do we grind out?
We do the derivatives
of x to the n.
Every calculus book starts
with x squared and finds
the derivative of x to the n.
Then you do sine x and cos x.
Then what others?
Are there any more?
e to the x-- good, e to the x.
And it's the inverse
function log.
In freshman calculus,
you always write ln, just
to be out of date.
OK.
And now that may be the list.
Is it?
And then the chain rule.
Are there others that you
actually do a computation of?
Actually, e to the x is
defined by the property
that its derivative
is e to the x.
And then you discover
what log x has to be.
And sine x-- how do you
do sine of x plus delta x?
Well, compare minus sine of x.
How do you find the hard
way, once-and-for-all way?
You draw a little unit circle
and mess with some angles.
And you discover that the
derivative of the sine
is the cosine.
That's if you've defined
the sine as a ratio of sides
in a right triangle.
Of course, you could define
it as an infinite series.
And then you would be
back to just using that.
OK.
So calculus does exactly
what we're doing here--
finds all derivatives
by the chain rule
applied to a few ones that
it has worked out in detail.
But tangent of x, we would
use the quotient rule.
Secant of x, we would use the
quotient rule, 1 over cosine.
And the products, we
use the product rule.
So really, calculus tends
to seem fairly simple
when you look back to see
what, actually, you did.
And then integration-- what
is integral calculus about?
More or less
guessing the answer.
You have to integrate f of x dx.
So really, what you have
to do is sort of think, OK,
what had this derivative?
What function had
that derivative?
And mess around and get it.
So really, it's a
freshman course, I guess.
OK.
So where am I?
Backward.
Right.
That's the thing still to do.
How does the
backward system work?
OK, I'll try my best.
OK.
So here is the big goal.
Back-- so reverse mode AD.
Right.
And let me make
myself a little note.
The little note is to give
you another example where
the order that you
do the computations
makes a big difference.
And that's not
obvious that it will.
There are many things
in math that you
could do in either order.
And it seems like, logically,
you've done the same things.
So another, and
simpler, example which
shows how one way could be
way faster than another way
is when I'm multiplying
three matrices.
So I'm multiplying
three matrices--
A times B times C.
And the question is, do I do BC
first and then multiply by A?
Or do I do AB first and
then multiply that by C?
And of course, I
kept them in order--
in the order ABC.
But the order of computations
can be different.
You get the right
answer both ways.
But those can be completely,
completely different.
One can be 1,000 times
faster than the other.
So that's just to show--
actually, it kind
of connects to this.
And there is also another--
so I'll do that, too.
So this is example 2, where
this is meant to be example 1.
And example 3 leads to something
called the adjoint method
in differential equations
or in optimization--
in computing optimum
and maximizing it.
Yeah.
Really, the underlying
reason it gives us speed-up
is, it makes the right choice
in a product of three things.
Yeah.
So it'll be enough to do
example 1 and example 2.
OK, let me go with example 1.
This is now back propagation.
Finally, we got to it.
OK.
Well, I look at my
notes is how I do it.
So the notes-- this
is section 7.2--
does these computational graphs.
And then here is reverse mode.
So it starts over
here with the--
so I'm going to
use the chain rule.
So dF dF is 1.
And then I'm going backwards.
And of course, I have
to use the right rule.
So I have to use
the product rule.
And then soon I'll
have to use these power
rule and linear rules.
So of course, no change there.
The change is that
by going backwards--
oh, I don't know if I
completed that sentence,
that I could find 100
partial derivatives,
if the function depended
on 100 variables,
in about five times the
cost of one variable--
three to five times
the cost of one.
So you would expect 100 chain
rules would cost 100 times.
But you see, we're reusing
the pieces in the chain
and just having a larger--
our chain is wider.
But it's not longer.
And it's not repeated.
Anyway, so here I'm going
to use whatever it is--
dF dc and dF ds.
And I'm remembering that--
yeah, OK.
So dF dc is s, and dF ds is c.
That was because F
started out as c times s.
It was the product.
OK.
Then we've got to
evaluate those.
And I'll look again to see
that I'm hopefully writing down
some of the correct things.
OK.
So now what I've written
down next is dF dc is 5.
Or no, 5 on that example.
What is it here? dF dc is--
c is x cubed.
So dF-- oh, sorry, dF dc--
yeah, I want s.
I'm looking for s here.
Yeah.
I'm looking for s.
So I'm looking for s.
And that's x plus 3y.
Am I doing this well?
I want, in the end, to get
the derivatives with respect
to x and y-- the whole gradient.
OK.
I think we started right.
The first derivatives
is to write c and s.
And then let me leave
these boxes open,
just to get the picture.
Then I'll need dc dx,
dc dy, ds dx, and ds dy.
I think that's right.
Here, I had a
product of c and s.
So I had two derivatives.
Here I have c and s,
each to differentiate.
So have an x and a y derivative
of x and a y derivative.
And now it's just a matter
of putting in those numbers
and following the
chain backwards.
Maybe I'm not going to
put those numbers in,
because if I didn't
reach 140, you wouldn't
believe in back propagation.
And that would be
an unhappy outcome.
So I'll leave you to
put them in maybe.
Or the notes have a separate
example that you can see.
But do you see the point--
that in the end, I'm
going to find dF dx and dF
dy from the chain--
from one chain and not
from a separate chain for x
and a separate chain for y.
To me, that's the
point of reverse mode.
It's a little bit of magic.
But you see the steps--
the ingredient.
And some of you have seen
this before and maybe
know a better exposition.
I found this blog by
Christopher Olah clear.
And these very simple
things, you'll see,
are clear in the notes.
But maybe another blog brings
out other points to make here.
It's not obvious, maybe, that
I could have 100 variables
and do the calculation in
four or five times the cost--
four or five times
being instead of 100.
Yeah.
But it's possible.
OK.
So could I close
today with this one?
How could those be different?
You're computing the same
numbers, the same AIJ, BJKs,
CKLs, and doing these sums.
But it certainly is different.
So let's just do that.
OK.
I'll do it here.
And then at the
right time-- and I
guess it'll be after Professor
Rao on Friday and Monday,
I'll come back to
Professor Sra's short proof
of the convergence of
stochastic gradient descent.
The whole point is to show you
what assumptions do you need.
You need some assumptions on
the gradient, some assumptions
on the step size.
And for a good proof, all
the assumptions fit together,
and, dong, out comes
the conclusion.
And the conclusion would
be how fast it converges--
stochastic gradient descent.
So there's some expected
things, because it's stochastic.
We expect some assumptions
about the mean and the variance
to go into the proof.
So you'll see that.
But maybe it's too
much for today.
So I'll come back to that.
I might even put it on Stellar
and just close with this.
So suppose A is m by n, B
is n by p, and C is p by q.
OK.
How many steps does it take
to find A times B times C--
the product of those
three matrices?
Well, if I go this way,
I have to do BC first.
So BC costs-- how
many operations
to multiply that times that?
npq-- nice formula.
npq.
Why is that?
Well, I could say that
the answer is n by q.
And every number in there
was an inner product
of a row and column of length p.
So I have nq inner products.
And each one costs p--
multiply, adds.
So now I have BC,
which will be--
so now I have m by n.
Then I have m by n,
which is the A times
B by C, which is now n by q.
That's BC.
This is A, BC.
And this one costs--
what's the cost here?
m by n, m by q--
by the same rule, it'll be mnq.
Good.
That's the first way--
A times BC.
Now, the second way is AB
times C. Let me write in again,
m by n, n by p, p by q.
So now I'm doing this first--
so AB costs.
Tell me again now,
what's the rule
for the cost of a
matrix multiplication?
mnp.
And then I multiply m by p--
that's AB-- times p by q.
That's C.
So I have mpq.
So I have that together
with that, or that
together with that.
That sum-- those
two or these two.
And they're different.
And let's just recognize
the most important example.
Suppose C is a column vector--
C for column vector.
So q is 1.
There's only one column.
So if q is 1, this way did np--
let's just specialize to that.
So specialize to C
equal a column vector,
which means that q is 1.
I only have one column.
So then A times BC
is versus AB times C.
So let's just figure
that out when q is 1.
So npq is just np.
And mnq is just mn,
where AB is m and p.
Oh, that's a bad one.
Disaster already.
Those are potentially
two big matrices,
multiplying a column vector.
So here I've done a
matrix multiplication.
I never should have done that.
This is a matrix vector.
It gives me a vector.
And then this is
a matrix vector.
So I get nice numbers here.
But I get a terrible
number for AB.
And then I multiply that
by C. So that's mpq.
mpq.
So mp is factoring out.
So if I write it as n times
m plus p versus this one
is m that's factoring
out times m--
no.
Yeah.
What's up here?
Sorry.
What am I doing?
Yeah.
Is it p that factors
out from this one?
OK.
p times m plus n, I guess.
Sorry.
Anyway, the difference is--
AUDIENCE: I think it's
mp times p plus q.
[INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: Shall I go
over it again or write--?
Let me do just this
thinking again.
If q is 1, if I go
this way, was that
my final total when q was 1?
And that's this?
No.
m factors out times n plus p.
Let's just get that right.
Oh, no, n factors out.
Sorry, n factors
out times m plus p.
And this way was
all these things.
AUDIENCE: Both the m
and the p factor out.
GILBERT STRANG: Both the
m and the p factor out.
OK.
Thanks.
Times n plus q.
n plus q was 1.
OK.
The whole point is, we've got
this horrible multiplication
of three big numbers.
And this only had
two big numbers.
So this is orders of
magnitude faster than that.
And of course, you would
have done the calculation.
That way, you would have
multiplied the column vector
by a matrix to get
another column vector.
And you would have
multiplied that by a matrix
to get another column
vector, where here,
you crazily multiplied two big
matrices together and then got
a column vector.
So there is a bad move.
OK, thanks.
Oh, I'm past the
time on this ABC.
It's just to show that on a
very familiar calculation,
you have to do it
in the right order.
And back propagation
is the right order
for partial derivatives.
OK.
Thank you.
And so bring laptops Friday.
And look forward
to Professor Rao.
Give him a good welcome.